I have to mention this is very weird
story in the last two months two people
have had heart attacks while eating at a
restaurant in Las Vegas called
the Heart Attack Grill now they're both
okay I got to stress that all right but
what's even crazier is they were both
eating what's called the double bypass
burger I'm not making this up this is
true they were eating the double bypass
burger when they had their heart attacks
at the heart attack groom now the
strange thing is I looked into what one
of the guys didn't see the warning signs
from all the other places he ate at
earlier in the week places like the
dangerously elevated cholesterol cafe we
should definitely seek medical attention
steakhouse do not ignore that tingling
sensation in left-turn pizzeria 98
percent arterial blockage burger bistro
what the hell is wrong with you you have
a family stop eating like this
restaurant
this is really reckless after eating at
the Heart Attack Grill and being
released from the hospital he went
directly to the lightning never strikes
twice barred and well
[Applause]